Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Rough.
>> Hi Martin. Why are we sitting at a round
table? We have a little bit of a
technical issue with our screen. Maybe
some people picked it up uh on the
previous WhatsApp profs that the
backdrop is a little bit shrunken.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so yeah, we're trying to sort that
out. So for in the meanwhile, we'll just
use a little bit of other space here.
>> We'll use some other space. Okay. So
instead of asking how we are, we're
asking how's our set? Is it coming on?
Is it getting better?
>> We hope it will be back to normal very
soon. But okay, that's also a a
definition problem. What is normal?
>> Nothing is normal.
>> Not anymore.
>> No.
>> Yeah. So, you want to briefly just say
how this came about?
>> Yes.
We've had discussions now with uh a
number of very interesting people that
are into
this uh millennial reconstruction
and uh people that want to see uh a
society where the church can bring in
morality and normality in order to
counteract the chaos that is in the
world and not only the chaos but the
violence and the depravity and
everything that goes with it and uh they
believe the time is now for that
millennial period to arrive.
And we had a discussion with Lenox and
then we had the privilege to have a
discussion with Wilson.
And these are very very important and
people tend to misunderstand what we are
doing or why we are doing it.
>> Complaining about why do you give him so
much air time platforms and this and
that and the other. The issue at stake
is where are we in the stream of time
and the urgency that the evangelical
world has to rectify the situation in
the world and the fear that the window
of opportunity to rectify it seems to be
fading and if you do not act now
then the problem will become greater and
exacerbated.
etc. So strike while the iron is hot and
uh the idea was not to to to give a
platform. The idea was to show what is
the thinking pattern that we are
confronted with.
>> You know we've for how many years have
we been speaking about this?
>> Many years. And many times people would
have would say but there it's not a a
danger because they're such a minuscule
group.
>> Yes,
>> they don't have any clout.
>> But then we showed over the time how
that uh mindset and how that thinking
pattern has been incorporated into the
political system of the world. How in
the United States of America, the movers
and the shakers, the top people whether
in Congress or wherever in the
administration
have that mindset.
>> Yeah. And the Supreme Court is largely
Roman Catholic run. And uh the people
that are in charge of the military and
of the the secret uh police and the FBI
and the CIA and all of these they are
now a group that has a certain cohesion
in terms of this thinking pattern.
Then the the religious aspect was
brought into the White House. Even
though many complained that it was
contrary to the constitution, it has
been established.
>> And the evangelical mindset is having a
an impact such as never before. And now
you have a an administration
that is in favor of these Christian
principles being enforced or at least
brought into the mainline society with
the support of the state.
>> And this is the opportunity and the
issue that we discussed is all right now
what if we do get the society.
>> Mhm. What if the society is implemented
then there will obviously also according
to the documents 2025
etc the conservative agenda there will
be a legislation
regarding a day of rest.
>> Yeah.
>> And so we discussed the issue and
well yes society is in a mess but can
you legislate morality? That was the
point
>> we mentioned in in there and we'll say
it again. Whenever morality is
legislated, blood will flow.
>> Correct? And we pointed to history and
we pointed to all of these facts. And
the mindset is we've learned from
history. We're not going to repeat the
mistakes.
But when you push the issue regarding
the Sabbath Sunday, can two walk
together less they agree, the issue is
no. The one party will want to stick to
the Sunday agenda and rationalize it and
the other party will stick to the
Sabbath agenda and back it with the
scriptures and never the twain shall
meet. And we will show that when we had
the discussion with Lenox,
it was basically stated that the
solution really is for the one party to
give way.
>> Yeah. Just for the Sabbathkeeping, just
come over to Sunday. That will solve it.
Correct. And we also had the the when we
had the discussion with Wilson, he also
stated and people can go and watch it
again that
uh is it
will it be so bad if a minority group is
not adhered to
>> stating that.
>> So let's let's look at that unpack that
argument a little bit.
>> Society is in such a dire straits that
if we do not act now the whole of
society will collapse.
Now what if one little group is in
juxtaposition and doesn't want to go
along with the majority in terms of this
the collateral damage of removing one
little group for the greater good of the
society. Isn't that uh a lesser of two
evils? It wasn't explicitly said like
this but it was implied.
>> Yes. because he was say saying it's so
bad now wouldn't it just be better if we
can start legislating.
>> Okay. Now Martin that reminds me of what
Kaiapas said. Uh isn't it expedient that
one man should die and his thinking and
ideology rather than that the whole
nation go to pot? Now let's globalize
that. Isn't it better that one group
that seems to be in disharmony with the
direction of sorting out the immorality
in the world, if they are removed for
the sake of the greater good of getting
the entire society back on track, that
would be a lesser of two evils. It would
still be an evil, but it would be a
lesser of two evils. And to the credit
of the parties, they both asserted that
they would not be instrumental in
persecution.
>> So all the people that we've spoken to
directly, they said they will be on our
side.
>> Correct. stating that for our
>> but when we showed that history
>> showed the opposite that eventually it
does lead to persecution and it does
lead to uh the very events that the
Bible has portrayed because in history
it has always been like that. So our
point in creating this discussion
is not to debate at this stage whether
Sunday or Sabbath is the correct one. We
have a position and we are settled in
the truth and cannot be moved on the
issue.
>> The other party also has a position and
is settled and cannot be moved on the
position. So they're going to be at
loggerheads in the end. That is what the
Bible says will happen with the
situation of the mark of the beast. Is
that right?
>> That's correct.
>> Fine. Okay. So we have a position. The
position is also not do we believe that
Christ will return before the millennium
or will he return after the millennium?
We have a position.
>> Yeah.
We believe that the scripture says
according to prophecy in Daniel and
elsewhere that the kings of the world
will set up a system where they control
the moral issues. But the Bible says
that God will intervene, wipe away all
of those and set up a kingdom that will
never be moved. So the kingdom of God
comes not by man implementing it but by
God implementing it. They believe no
they will sort it out and then Christ
will come. And those two positions are
again in ju position. Our motivation is
not necessary to show that our arguments
are so much better although of course we
believe they are.
>> Mh. and to convince them to change their
mind because scripture tells us they
won't.
>> Yeah.
>> Therefore, what is our position? Our
position is get ready. Get ready
>> because we are on the threshold of these
events. And people that claimed no,
we're going to put it off for way long
as they themselves in their interviews
said hundreds of years, 200, 250 years
at least until these things, you know,
come into fruition. We are saying no, it
can happen immediately. It will come as
an overwhelming
surprise.
>> Yeah.
>> And therefore the question is, are we
ready? And let's unpack it clearly.
>> If they believe that they only have a
short window of opportunity which is now
available because there is an
administration in place that is willing
to stick its neck out in this regard.
>> Well Martin that administration will be
reassessed in the year 2028.
>> Yeah.
Therefore, the window of opportunity if
they want to use this opportunity
is now between now, which is the middle
of 2025 to 2028.
That is a very short window.
>> Now, we've had many, many discussions in
the past as to what the signs of the
times is, what the esoteric world says,
what the biblical chronology says. And
we've we've been in trouble because of
it.
>> Yeah.
>> We never made a date.
>> No,
>> we are talking about events and we
always said Christ can prolong the time
or he can shorten the time. That's not
for us to decide.
But the fact of the matter is we said
the events can happen within a very
short period of time. Now if they have
this drive to implement it before the
opportunity goes away
>> then I believe that it is possible let's
make it very plain it is possible
that the events that are pres described
in the Bible can actually start being
implemented within the next short
period. period of time
>> and that these events because of the
time frame can be very rapid ones
>> and come as an overwhelming
surprise and I believe as we've stated
many times in the past that God gave us
a practice run.
>> Yeah. Didn't that come as an
overwhelming surprise when we had the
pandemic or whatever you want to call
it? Didn't that come as an overwhelming
surprise?
>> And didn't the world change from one day
to the next?
>> Oh, very much. It's never gone back. It
won't go back. Our normality today is
not what it was 5 years ago.
>> No, it's a new normal.
>> A new normal. And they stated it will
be.
>> Okay. So let's have a look at some of
these issues and just unpack it a little
bit.
>> Yeah. Put it into perspective with some
videos and quotes.
>> And the the aim again is to say
overwhelming surprise
if we know the scriptures. Should it be
an overwhelming surprise or should the
watchman be sitting on the wall or
standing on the wall watching the events
out there and crying aloud to the people
inside that is the church
and say to them I know that it is very
dark out here now. I know it's midnight
and I know that all of you are sleeping
down there, but we see something
approaching where we would like to wake
you up because the sound of your snoring
is so loud at the moment that it would
wake up a bear.
Can you please please wake up
>> and get ready?
>> That's the purpose of what we are doing.
>> Let's pray. Let's
>> and let's get into this.
>> Our heavenly father,
we are privileged to be seeing these
things happen before our eyes. We are
privileged to live in the times that we
are living. But without you, it will not
be worth anything. So we ask that you
enlighten our minds. Help us to put this
together and help the viewers and
everybody watching this and listening to
this to take it and we can so that we
can warn the world in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Just a question
to be awakened and ready
even if it doesn't take place. Is it
worse or better than staying asleep and
being surprised with an overwhelming
surprise?
>> For sure it's better. It's like um one
isn't it a argument that somebody had
some time and said, "I'll rather live
that than I'll rather live as if there
is a God and find out there is not one
than living as if there's not a God and
then find out there is one."
>> Yes, that's a good point. And you know
the argument that people have is how you
going to get all these nations on board?
They're all ideologically in a different
place, right? Okay.
>> It's never going to happen. Well, how
did you get all the nations on board
overnight in the pandemic?
>> That's what that's your go-to.
>> If ever you had a question and if you
still have a doubt that should show you.
A lot of people had the argument but
people will kick against it so they
won't be implementing it nationwide
>> or worldwide.
>> Oh yeah,
>> they did kick against it. Did it help
them?
>> Nothing. Then you get arrested or get
thrown in jail or ostracized so that
your credentials is even worth nothing.
>> Yes. In some in some countries they came
with their mounted police and rode over
the people with their horses.
>> You will do what you are told and that's
it. So Martin,
let us have a look at what we can glean
from all of these things. Here is a a
quote from child guidance and it talks
about an overwhelming
surprise.
Transgression has almost reached its
limit. Confusion fills the world and a
great terror is soon to come upon human
beings. The end is very near. God's
people should be preparing for what is
to break upon the world as an
overwhelming
surprise.
Our time is precious. We have but a few
a very few days of probation in which to
make ready for the future immortal life.
Martin, there seems to be a sense of
urgency in that statement. Definitely.
So, what do God's people need now?
Martin, if they're asleep, can they be
working on their revival and
reformation?
>> No.
>> No. They're they're snoring, right?
>> And I'm afraid they are snoring.
Christians should be preparing for what
is soon to break upon the world as an
overwhelming surprise.
And this preparation they should make by
diligently studying the word of God and
striving to conform their lives to its
precepts. God calls for a revival and a
reformation. Two things.
Uh some people have claimed of course
that the two are the same thing. No,
because a revival can be very emotional
with very little substance.
So without a reformation you have a
problem right?
>> If you have been gone astray and doing
some things a revival will not help that
you have to reform yourself and get back
to
>> so what we need is a revival of true
godliness amongst us and it is the most
urgent of all our needs and this should
be our first work to seek this. The time
has come for a thorough reformation to
take place. When this reformation
begins, the spirit of prayer will
actuate believers and will banish from
the church the spirit of discord and
strife.
>> There was a moment when people woke up
thought well this is serious. They
started praying like crazy eventually
where where we are now and everybody's
back to sleep.
>> Mhm.
A revival and reformation must take
place under the ministration of the Holy
Spirit. Revival and reformation are two
different things.
Revival signifies a renewal of spiritual
life, a quickening of the powers of the
mind and heart, a resurrection from
spiritual death. But reformation
signifies a reorganization,
a change in ideas and theories, habits
and practices. You have to practically
apply what the scripture says.
And if you haven't been doing it,
Martin,
then it becomes time to do it because
the urgency is now there.
So reformation will not bring forth the
good fruit of righteousness unless it is
connected with the revival of the
spirit. So revival and reformation are
to do their appointed work. And in doing
this work they must blend. You must be
on fire.
You must have the motivation of the Holy
Spirit. And then you must do. Now what
will you say if people come to you and
say ah you see so we must start
something new because this the the
current system of what we dealing with
our church has to be reformed. But are
we harborous of truth
or of little conclaves of discussions?
If we unify on the truth, then we will
run with the truth and the rest will
fall in place.
>> So am I okay in saying this? It says
reformation signifies a reorganization,
a change in ideas and theories, habits
and practices. This does not mean this
is a personal thing. It's a personal
thing where you have not been living in
harmony with what the scriptures have
been saying.
>> So this is not reorganizing the
organization.
>> No, this is reorganizing the heart a
personal
change.
So Martin, let's see if we can
reorganize in terms of the urgency of
the times. Is it so that we can tell
people wake up where are on the
threshold? If you haven't been doing
this work, you better do it now because
when it happens and you wake up and you
start trimming your lamps, you might
find that you don't have oil.
>> Now is the time to get that oil now.
>> All right, let's look at the
circumstances and see what we can glean.
The world is a theater.
The actors, its inhabitants are
preparing to act their part in the last
great drama. With the great masses of
mankind, there is no unity.
>> That's often used as an argument. It'll
never happen because they're not
unified.
>> But they certainly got unified very
quickly.
>> Mhm.
>> On the pandemic, right? And doesn't
matter what country, what religion, they
all got unified.
>> They were unified.
>> God is looking on. His purposes in
regard to his rebellious subjects will
be fulfilled.
The world has not been given into the
hands of men. Though God is permitting
the elements of confusion and disorder
to bear sway for a season, a power from
beneath is working to bring about the
last great scenes of the drama. And one
of those scenes, Martin, will be Satan
coming as Christ and working with all
deceivleness of unrighteousness in those
who are binding themselves together in
secret societies.
>> Those who are yielding to the passion
for confederation
are working out the plans of the enemy.
The cause will be followed by the
effect. So Martin, what we have been
preaching for years seems to be
inculcated in this one statement. Yeah,
because it links on and all this deceess
and unrighteousness and all these things
because it is coming Christ is coming as
Christ. There's a portion that I believe
we can also say when we have these
discussions with these guys that's also
they coming in as defenders of Christ.
>> Correct.
>> But they it's it's not the right thing
to do. And you know they might have an
appearance of morality and they might
belonging to secret societies and maybe
they have many a skeleton in their
cupboard and maybe they're even covering
up skeletons in their cupboards whether
it's little islands with debortched
activities on it or not. That's not the
issue. What is the tendency in terms of
the implementation of moral values
supported by the church? And I'm not
even saying that the churches that are
implementing them are necessarily always
on the right side of that moral issue.
>> So Martin, here's something which is
probably
let's say uh not the most credible of
sources in the world, but it's
interesting.
>> Yeah. If we can hear some directly from
how these guys think or so on, it's very
we have to listen to what they have been
talking about in their spheres as well.
I mean, we look at Blavadski and at
Bailey and what they said about what
will happen in
>> and we consider them credible.
>> So, we can have a little listen. So,
here's a former church leader of Satan
and he wants to expose the satanic
agenda for the years 2025 to 2027.
Now, those dates are of course very
interesting because we have an agenda
uh which is being implemented as we've
seen in our previous WhatsApp profs. uh
we have made statements about 2027.
Not that we said that that is when the
end comes but we said that these dates
are fascinating.
>> Yeah.
>> For various reasons. So let's hear what
the man has to say.
>> I was the leader of a satanic
organization. I saw the satanic agenda
with my own eyes. I was in meetings
discussing the satanic agenda with other
satanic organizations around the world.
So every 9 years it gets updated. So I'm
just aware of the one that's being
pushed now up to 2027. I don't know what
the genoa is after that, but what I've
seen with my own eyes and the the online
conferences that I've been in with other
satanic leaders, this is what's going on
at the moment. When I said I left when I
left Satanism um in May 2022,
when I left Satanism, I said, and I have
a recording of it, I said that in 2025,
people will be arrested on the street
for praying for other people. People
will be prosecuted for being Christians
in Europe. I said that because I saw it
on the agenda. It it wasn't a prophecy
or that I saw the future. It was because
I knew what was on the agenda and people
thought I was insane. So I'm saying
today that in 2027 there's going to be a
one world religion that will be the
acceptable and the only religion around
the world that will be legal and it's
not going to be Christianity. Now,
Martin, when he says it's not going to
be Christianity,
well, Martin, could it be a brotherhood
of religions?
>> I think so. He mentioned that he's he
thinks because he doesn't know because
that wasn't said which religion it would
be. He thinks it would be Islam. But
what you've just mentioned, we've got
the Brotherhood, we've got the Abrahamic
>> Accord. Yes. Now it could be as we said
like uh the previous pope said a
fraternity.
>> He was pushing the issue of fraternity
and uh in Christian nations it would be
a Christian flavor.
>> Whereas in Islamic nations it would be a
Islamic flavor etc. depending on where
you are in the world. But there would be
a joint agenda which would incorporate
morality
>> and saying that it won't be a Christian
religion.
When you take the Abrahamic Accords, the
Christian portion according to them,
that doesn't qualify to be Christian.
>> No, because it denies the atonement. But
leave leave that apart. Now in a
Christian nation, you could have
Christian morality.
>> Yeah.
>> Now what what legislation could be
universal
in terms of Christianity, Islam or any
other religion? Isn't it a day of rest
that one could unite upon? Mhm.
>> And what if that day of rest was
actually initiated by the beast, which
is Catholicism,
then wouldn't the mark of its
ecclesiastical power become a universal
mark? Whether for climate reasons or for
religious reasons, then becomes
irrelevant.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> If it's just for economic and
environmental reasons, that's good
enough. It's still the same legislation.
We've always said that because people
will would ask okay but if they want to
if it's for Sunday what will get the
atheist and the other religions to
>> accept it
>> accept it and we've always said one of
the biggest ways to do that will be the
climate
>> correct now in Islamic nations
are there moral laws and moral codes
>> yes there are dress codes there are all
kinds of codes
>> and do they have a particular law that
deals with that moral situation, isn't
it? Sharia law.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the other nations already have moral
legislation.
>> It's the Christian nations that don't
have it. So, they could implement it
>> and many of them we could agree on.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> But when it comes to the day of rest, we
cannot agree on it because they are two
opposites. And the one according to the
scripture is the sign or the mark of the
authority of God which is the Sabbath.
>> And according to Catholicism and the
evangelical world, it is the Sunday that
gives them the authority
to implement their moral values. Right?
So this is where we would be at
loggerheads with the system. So I don't
think what he said there about
Christianity being gone but biblical
Christianity yeah
>> will be confronted that is the issue now
did it come true what he said are people
being arrested for praying for people or
for even in their mind praying or
addressing issues such as abortion or
whatever and the answer is obviously
Yes. So, show a few videos, Martin.
>> So, as far as So, as far as I know, I'm
quoting a Bible, preaching my faith,
>> and I'm being harassed by the police now
for being
>> What did I I didn't do anything illegal.
>> Whilst you're speaking to the camera
about being harassed by the police,
you're not being harassed by the police.
We've just had numerous calls through to
our control, which hence why we're here.
So the call. So basically anybody can
lie about somebody and say they're
bothering me and therefore I have to be
shut down because someone produces
>> but we need to be seen to look into it.
>> Yeah. At the moment we're not we're not
shutting you down or anything. It's just
that we got so many numerous calls
through that we have to come and speak.
>> I think there's a few people that's
offended.
>> That doesn't mean that there's an
offense being committed.
>> I appreciate that. The I don't there's
no problem in regards to your freedom
expression. Okay. Nobody's questioning
that. The bottom is somebody's made an
allegation that what you've been saying
has caused them to fear due to a hate
crime element. Okay. That's why I'm
here. Okay. Not to do with your freedom
of expression. Okay. In regards to
whatever you're expressing. Okay. I
think it's the the topic that's caused
the reason that I'm here. All right.
>> For an offense for for there to be an
offense of section 4A or section five,
okay, I would have to be guilty of using
threatening,
abusive, or insulting words. And that's
certainly not what I'm doing
from the Bible that way. Guilty. Even if
that's not your that's not your
intention. Somebody has felt that way
and therefore they rang us. Do you
understand that?
>> Yeah. I do understand that.
>> I told you to watch what you were saying
because people are no finish.
>> People are saying that they are offended
by what you're saying. Now, if we get
complaints to say that somebody is
offended, then we have ground to arrest.
>> What ground? Under what law?
>> Under Scottish law.
>> What law? What? What? What?
>> Justice law.
>> So, what's what's the offense then?
Somebody's offended.
>> It's not a hate crime. Somebody's
offended.
>> Hate crime.
>> Somebody's offended.
>> The Bible is offensive.
>> And I have every religious freedom in
this land purchased by the crown. By the
way, the crown, the very Bible that our
king and his coronation put his hand
upon and swore an oath to the people, I
have every right to preach the Bible.
>> Well, don't preach to me, right? Cuz I'm
trying to do my job.
>> You're asking me?
>> Well, Martin, the fact is that they
claim that if somebody is offended, then
you can be arrested. Right. Now, Martin,
if you preach that a certain religious
system is the antichrist, wouldn't some
people be offended? about more than a
billion at least, right? Some others as
well.
>> It's not that big. Just over a billion.
>> It's it is exactly. So, it's just for me
it's a it's um interesting to see that
they say we're not um we don't argue
that you've got freedom of speech and
you can but but you're as long as you're
offending somebody, you don't have it
anymore.
>> Correct. Now what that ex Satanist said,
he was talking about a a plan for 2025
to 2027.
Now in 2025
we are told by the esoteric world that
there will be an externalization of the
hierarchy. So in some way the demonic
forces must have direct access and
influence over society,
over leaders in society, over
governments, over policies
and the question is is there any
movement in that direction? Now we're
not going to repeat what somebody has
already done a very good job on. Uh
Matthew Sanche had a a talk the other
day on is the false Christ about to
appear
and he deals with this very issue of the
predictions of Alice A Bailey for 2025
and he explains that there were meetings
where this was discussed and how far
along this issue has progressed. Yeah,
there's a document about a reporter that
really
>> goes into detail detail with it
>> and he did a great job and there is the
the link on the screen. We'll also have
it in the descriptions
and I advise everyone to go and see what
ma Matthew Sanche has actually put out
with his colleagues and uh they did a
wonderful job and I think it's worth
watching. So go and watch his channel
and uh see what he had to say on the
issue. The fact of the matter is that
that which Alice A. Bailey said many
many years ago is actually coming to
fruition in the time that we are living
in. And then of course we also have
these massive manifestations of UFOs and
alien connections and this and that and
the news is full of that at the moment.
>> The latest one I saw is um that object.
No, it wasn't object. is light that they
saw with a telescope and now they
believe that the way it's approaching it
cannot be a comet.
>> Correct. This professor at the
university stated that it was a
spaceship
>> connect somebody making trying to make
contact probably.
>> Yes. And it was nuclear powered because
it had a light in front and not the
light in the tail like in a normal
comment. Be that as it may, this idea of
we're coming into contact with the world
out there is very prominent.
And we've had talks on other forums
where we dealt with UFOs.
>> Yes. With Strange Normal and um Bradley,
we had that interview with him. He's
still producing very good um episodes.
>> Correct. Also the people that we had
with um Heritage and Hope that we did
the interviews with Lenox and uh Doug
Wilson with they also had a very good um
collaboration with Strange Normal and
Bradley. So, we've been on those forums
and people can look and we believe that
these are demonic manifestations because
this this world that we are on right
now, this world is the one where the sin
question will be dealt with.
>> And we know who is down here. We have a
demonic world and we have a human world
down here. And the one is going to
manifest itself. In other words, take an
active part in events. Whereas before it
was behind the scenes in secret
societies and satanic organizations and
rituals and calling up demons, etc.,
etc. Whether it happened in a church
setup, so-called church setup, or
whether it happened in secret societies
is irrelevant at this point. But it was
behind the scenes and it was secret.
>> Now it become mainstream. Yeah.
>> And become open.
>> And hasn't Hollywood propagated that
over the years?
>> Oh man, they've got an agenda.
>> Correct. So he said it'll start
manifesting in 2025. We are seeing it in
2025. Watch Matthew Sanchez documentary
and determine whether that is so or
whether that is not so. But we're moving
along in time. So let's talk about the
evangelical position
or let's talk about some of the
evangelicals in the world that are
driving this issue that now is time to
strike because the window of opportunity
to cail the evil is slowly passing away.
>> So if we don't act now it'll be too
late.
>> Yeah. So they've they're using this
small like you mentioned the opportunity
of this current administration in the
US.
>> Correct. And you had Lenox that we spoke
to who's in the same sphere but uh we
also want to know what Douglas Wilson
had to say because his influence is just
so much greater and his influences
stretches right into the echelons of
power. and we've had this wonderful
privilege of also being able to speak to
him besides Lenox. So let's have a look
at some of his uh previous discussions.
He had discussions with Tucker Carlson
and he had discussions with uh CNN. So
obviously this issue is now very broadly
being discussed. Let's have a look at
some of these things.
>> All law is imposed morality.
By definition,
>> by definition, it's not whether but
which.
>> It's not it's not whether you're
imposing morality, it's which morality
you're imposing.
>> Okay? Uh and if someone says, "Well, you
this is going to you're going to wind up
imposing morality." I say, "Well, yeah,
that's what law is, right? You can't
have a structured ordered society
without the imposition of morality."
>> Law is judgment,
>> right? But then that leads to the
question, which morality? every every
moral system arises out of the worship
of a god. All right? So in Saudi Arabia,
you're going to get a moral system that
is distinctly different than a moral
system that arose out of a country with
the Christian history and consensus. All
right? So the the God you worship, this
is a principle you see all through the
through the entire Bible. Uh and that is
you become like what you worship. you uh
people begin to be conformed to the
image of what they consider to be the
highest good. You become like what you
worship.
>> Okay. So Martin, if you are in a
Christian nation,
that is what you want. Now let's get
this straight. Many of the Christian
nations have been inundated
with migrants.
>> Mhm. Oh yeah. And in some of the nations
those migrants can be from other
religious systems particularly in Europe
>> and that affects the identity of that
nation or that continent. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> So there are moves of foot to say that
we do not want to be associated with the
morality that is associated for example
with Islam. We don't want to be under
Shariah law. We'd rather have Christian
norms. And that is where even the
scientists and the atheists in the world
eventually come to the conclusion, no,
I'm a
>> cultural
>> a cultural Christian, right?
>> Because I'd rather be under that set of
laws than in the other. But in the
meantime, migration is increasing and
the continents, whether it be Germany or
whether it be England or whether it be
any of the others are becoming more and
more Islamatized
>> and there's a movement of foot. No,
we're going to get rid of all the
illegal aliens
>> or let's say all of those that do not
want to conform to our set of standards.
It's almost like a patriotism
uh resurgence. It's
>> correct.
>> And the left has always been very open
to this blending and the right has been
very anti- this blending. So whether you
talk about the issue in France or
whether you talk about the issue in
England or Germany, this is a great
divide
>> and at the moment the ones that hold
sway are more the ones that are on the
liberal side and we said the pendulum
will start swinging.
>> It did swing in the US
>> and the US would take the lead and it's
doing
>> question
did the US start taking the lead? for
sure.
>> Did they start saying no, we need
Christian norms?
>> Trump Yes, that for sure.
>> Did he introduce into the White House a
system to have a look at that that
Christianity should no longer be trotten
upon?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Did he act upon migrants?
>> In the latest interview that I saw, he
said, is it in the past 90 days not one
illegal immigrant passed over the
border? Okay. Now, now it's interesting
in the United States, most of the
immigrants that come in are not
necessarily from another religious
system other than Christianity.
Many of them are from South America that
are actually Catholic.
But the problem is that they align
themselves with liberal thinking, in
other words, with the left.
>> Yeah. And so they will rather tolerate
woke and other problems rather than
giving the right the power to get rid of
the the immigrants. So strike while the
iron is hot. Get rid of anyone that has
any connection to woke.
>> Yeah.
>> So there it is a king of the north king
of the south issue. And in the the rest
of Europe, it is a question of two
religious norms that are clashing.
Therefore, let us move back to our old
Christian roots. So, we have to look is
there a movement in that direction. Now,
as Wilson said, we want to implement
laws.
>> We want to implement morality. He said
so to Tuck.
>> What is law? He says that's a different
>> and the God that we serve is the God of
the Bible. is the Christian Bible,
the the the God of Christianity
and our laws are going to be Christian
laws. That's basically what he said.
Right now, in our discussion with Lenox,
what happened there?
>> Do you does your ideal political leader
get into power and then shoot the moon?
Um, Sabbath legislation,
the whole deal, or do you wait in from
the shallow end? You don't need you
don't actually don't need like a
majority support of the population. You
just need a strong willed minority. And
then th that ruling class can shape the
imagination of the majority which I
think Trump is doing now because for
decades we've had a very kind of weak
right when it comes to imposing your
will upon the executive branch. And now
he's actually revealing to the country
that, oh wait, there is this executive
who who's vested with the executive
power who can exercise power within his
branch. Um I I just don't think you
you're ever going to escape the nature
of politics which is agonistic. There's
a struggle. There's a point in which you
you debate and then if and then if you
win, you win and you essentially impose
your will upon those who disagree. So
when you have a blue when you have blue
laws, uh that's something that
Anglicans, congregationalists,
Presbyterians, Baptists can all agree
on. The 7th Day Adventists wouldn't, but
you know, things are tough all over.
>> Let's say labor laws make it almost
impossible to have two days because the
world is basically asking for a
synchronized day of rest. What if the
laws move in that direction? Then you
start legislating the first table of the
decalogue.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm in favor of legislating
the first table of the law. Now, if I
can imagine a a country where 99.9%
of the population
uh is observing the first day and the
guy who's got convictions that it's that
it's Wednesday, he's going to he's going
to have a tough time of it, right? I I
do think there's a great value in a
society being on the same clock. Our
concern is is that longterm down the
road, our people are going to be facing
imprisonment in the future as they did
back in 1888.
>> So, um, and if that were to happen, that
would be bad, right? But if that bad
thing happened, it would be way better
than what you're going through now.
>> How so?
>> Um, we we just finished slaughtering 60
million babies. What's the alternative?
The alternative is where we are now
where people are arguing for seriously
arguing for transhumanism
uh genetic engineering splicing human
beings with uh animals that we're we're
in the middle of a brave new world. And
I don't believe I don't believe that we
should be spooked by what some
Christians did 300 years ago and what
some Christians are talking about. Hey,
wouldn't it be nice, you know, if we
were to go back to that? I'm opposed to
that, but that's not the big danger
right now.
>> Six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work. Let's say I own a bakery and I'm
forced to close my business on Sunday.
Is that not impeding upon my free right
to keep the commandment and work six
days?
>> And again, this is I think where it gets
tricky. And I think for the sake of the
harmony of all of this, it would be much
easier if um my 7th day Adventist
friends just started to acknowledge
Sunday as the Lord's day. Then that way
we wouldn't run into those kinds of
issues. But I wouldn't say
>> you cannot because of the deadline.
>> That would be the simplest um most
orderly way to do it because the vast
majority let's say we have a Christian
nation. The vast majority of Christians
in North America observe Sunday as the
Lord's day. Um, and if this were a
seventh day Adventist country or if you
postulate the formation of an Adventist
country somewhere and I and I went
there, I would fully expect
uh to adjust myself to that custom of of
that people. But in order to have in
order to have that happen, you have to
have the numbers basically
>> because we look at what prophecy is
saying and where we are heading and we
see that all these tentacles are in
current currently in government and also
on the Supreme Court. the majority being
Roman Catholic and that bringing in all
the things is set up correctly that when
the Christian nationalism starts maybe
being implemented who will be the
driving force will it be a view like you
have or will it be coming from the Roman
Catholic side? I think that there are
people alive and ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar
ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar ar
ar ar ar ar ar ar argguing for things
who if they came out on top of the
Christian nationalist movement and they
were calling the shots uh they would be
saying things and doing things that you
guys wouldn't like at all. I think that
if I were in the position where I was
rep, you know, people and uh like me
were representing Christian nationalism,
I think you would have nothing to worry
about at all. I think that we have to
decide to do something. Martin the
interesting thing is
uh it would be better if we moved on our
position. Now the trouble is that this
book is very explicit
and therefore if we did move we would
violate our conscience in terms of what
this book has to say on the issue.
Right?
>> Or if we can put it bluntly we would
have changed one of the commandments.
>> We would have changed one of the
commandments. Now, Roman Catholicism
didn't have a problem with that. They
changed it.
>> They admit that they changed it and they
want to enforce it according to their
catechism and according to their
encyclicals
because Rum Novarum, which the present
pope stands for, said it is a law that
the state must legislate.
>> Must must
>> must legislate. And remember that um in
our discussion with um Doug Wilson,
Pastor Doug Wilson, we he said exactly
the same.
>> He said exactly the same. Now his
conviction also was that it had moved
from Sabbath to Sunday.
>> That's you remember what he what Lenox
just said. It was a whole shift in the
cosmos.
>> Yes.
>> That took place.
>> Correct. Now this is where we are going
to have a difference of opinion.
And it is fascinating to me that the
thinking as we said in the introduction
was that what is worse letting the whole
world go to pot or
making sure for the sake of unity that a
lesser evil in other words the division
on this point be removed in order to
save the whole world. And he was also
speaking about the minority.
>> The minority
>> because the majority will be following
the Sunday portion.
>> Correct. And we asked the question is
the majority necessarily right?
>> And they use the example Alex used it in
saying that when Jesus was on earth was
the majority right or was the minority
right?
>> Correct. So Martin this is very
fascinating. Now this let me let me put
this straight. This is not to attack
the people that we had interviews with.
>> I think we had very civil discussions
with them.
>> And yes, they will have as they claim no
drive to persecute anyone on that issue.
But the fact of the matter is that
history has shown that not everybody
will be on the same page in their camp
with this either. by them acknowledging
it as well.
>> Now Martin, here society finally decides
to set straight morality in the world by
legislation and one group says it's not
going along with it.
Surely some will come up with the
argument it is expedient that that group
be removed for the sake of the common
good.
>> Yeah.
>> Now who argues for common good? Doesn't
it the Roman Catholic system? That's
100% them.
>> Saman, the point is, are we at that
point
where these things can happen
as an overwhelming surprise?
>> If you if you're not watching it, for
sure it's going to take you an
overwhelming surprise.
>> Okay, let's listen to what Wilson had to
say on CNN.
>> A new church has quietly opened here in
Washington, just three blocks from the
nation's capital. The defense secretary
Pete Hexath attended the first service.
The church is part of the communion of
reformed evangelical churches and its
aim is global Christian domination under
a strict interpretation of the Bible.
>> Christ Church senior pastor Doug Wilson
makes no apologies for his beliefs on
God and country.
>> I'd like to see the town be a Christian
town. Like to see this the state be a
Christian state. Like to see the nation
be a Christian nation. And I'd like to
see the world be a Christian world.
>> And now Wilson's controversial views as
a Christian nationalist are gaining sway
in the nation's center of power with the
recent opening of his new church and
high-profile parishioners like Defense
Secretary Pete Hugset.
>> Is planting a church in DC part of your
mission to try to turn this into a
Christian nation?
>> Yes. So every society is theocratic. The
only question is who's Theo in a secular
democracy. It would be Deos, the people.
In a Christian republic, it'd be Christ.
>> Well, what would you say to someone
watching this to say, "Look, I'm I'm a
Muslim. Who are you to say your world
view is better than mine? That your God
is better than mine?"
>> Well, if I went to Saudi Arabia, I would
fully expect to live under their God's
rules.
>> But you said earlier that you want this
to be a Christian world. Yes.
>> So, you want to supplant their religion
with your Christian?
>> Yes. By peaceful means by sharing the
gospel. There's a lot of work yet to do.
I believe that we are working our little
corner of the vineyard.
>> He is rapidly gaining in power. He has
hundreds of churches established around
the the country. They actually literally
want to take over towns and cities and
they have access to this administration.
Wilson is part of a broader Christian
nationalist movement making inroads with
the Trump administration with a newly
created faith office led by evangelical
pastor Paula White Kaine and people seen
right outside the White House entrance
praying and speaking in tongues.
>> We are standing on the soil of the White
House and we are declaring your word.
>> How precious.
>> And now there's a monthly prayer service
at the Pentagon initiated by Hegath
Wilson's highest level connection to the
administration. It's not
organizationally tied to us, but it it's
the kind of thing we love to see.
>> For his part, Haggath has publicly
praised Wilson.
>> Now, we're standing on the shoulders of
a generation later um the Doug Wilsons
and the others.
>> Wilson's influence spans the globe with
more than 150 churches. Lennox Kellangua
moved to Moscow from Africa.
>> It's really because I wanted to be a
part of a community that was doing
something and especially in building
Christian institutions. Are there other
black families in this community?
>> Oh, absolutely. There there's a few
black families.
>> How far off do you see a Christian
nation? Like a full-on Christian
theocracy?
>> Oh, 250 years.
>> 250 years.
>> Yeah. Honestly, that's
>> that's what you see. But you do think it
will happen.
>> Yes, I do. We're not going to usher in
anything ourselves. We're really
genuinely pioneers.
>> CNN, by the way, reached out to the US
Defense Department to inquire about
Secretary Hex's relationship with Doug
Wilson. and a spokesperson said Hexath
is quote a proud member of the network
of churches founded by Wilson and that
the secretary quote very much
appreciates many of Mr. Wilson's
writings and teachings end quote.
>> Okay, Martin.
Now Martin, what is the possibility
given his statements to us about the
urgency of the situation
and that it has to be implemented and
just like Lenox who is in the same team
as them
>> stated the Sunday Sabbath issue will be
a point of discussion and it would just
be better for the Adventists just to
give up their Sabbath and go with the
flow, right?
>> Mhm.
What is the probability, Martin, that
two little ministries like Heritage and
Hope and Clash of Minds
should have this amazing
privilege
of being able to talk face to face with
both of these entities.
I think
that God opened a window here
>> and I am overwhelmed at the
responsibility that rests upon us. I
don't believe that what we said in those
interviews. I don't even believe that
the best arguments that you could ever
provide for our position is going to
sway anything.
But if it can wake people up that this
is the confrontation that is waiting for
us,
>> then they should wake up from their
slumber.
>> You know, in 1888
with presenting facts and persuasion,
they swayed the people.
>> But it's not going to happen the second
time.
>> This time and the Bible and the spirit
of prophecy says not the second time.
This is a second siege.
>> Correct? Let me get to another point
here.
Both of the individuals we spoke to said
it is not in them to persecute.
>> No.
>> But we claimed that history proves that
eventually such a conflict leads to
persecution.
Now many of the points that that drive
them issues of morality
>> we agree on.
>> Definitely
>> society is in a mess. And what a
wonderful world it would be if the whole
world would have
>> good Christian morality.
>> But the question is, can you legislate
it? Every time a nation in the past has
legislated it or a system has legislated
it, it led to persecution, bloodshed,
and catastrophe.
>> The point is, Martin, even though we
didn't sway them, that's not the point,
not the issue.
When the events take place,
they could make a decision for the other
side
>> because through our discussion, we have
actually told them that the scripture
says that this will happen.
>> This will happen many times.
>> And when they see it happen, I have this
hope.
>> And I believe I'm backed by the spirit
of prophecy that many will see it.
>> Yeah. and will come over. So this is not
a condemnation of Lenox and it's not a
condemnation of Wilson. It is an appeal
to them to make a determination
what is going to be the norm, the
consensus of society and the their
definition or the papal definition of
the common good
>> or the scripture.
>> You see that's one question we also
asked.
>> Yeah. If we see
the administration,
the Supreme Court and the movers and
shakers in there are part of the system
according to the Bible that's the
antichrist system. Martin, I believe God
opened a door. I believe God gave us an
opportunity to state a case. Whether
it's accepted or not at this stage is
irrelevant.
But I believe the fact that it happened
means that God wants us to wake up
because the time is short.
>> Yeah. And stuff is happening.
>> So let's just have a look at what the
Parliament of World Religions has
decided that it wants to do at its next
uh meeting. And here we have the triabic
dialogue on the climate crisis. And
we've always connected the climate
crisis to Sunday legislation in the past
and people can look at those those
presentations.
So what do our faiths demand
not suggest?
>> The tribrahamic dialogue on the climate
crisis. This webinar is a forum for
creation care leaders and grassroots
activists to analyze their communities
and strategic audiences in the concrete
situation of 2025.
It's fascinating how those two dates
keep coming up, right? panelists will
explain how Latusi
>> isn't that a Catholic document written
by the previous pope
and al-Misan which is an Islamic
document on the climate change
and other texts set the foundation for
effective action for climate that is
broad-based compassionate and at a scale
to the crisis.
Martin, let's be quite blunt. My
position at least is a created crisis
which doesn't exist. But nevertheless,
that's their problem.
>> In the light of the wisdom of the
Abrahamic faith.
>> Yeah. I just want to ask a question that
I've heard before.
So people said and I
they made statements that oh everybody
was waiting for the climate crisis to
bring in the Sunday law now they have
tomato on their faces. Is that true?
>> No.
>> Why not?
>> It's still working in the background. So
if this current administration Trump
that got rid of the Paris agreement
climbed out of them drill drill baby
drill and all of this like we've said
before if they want to implement the
Sundays a day of rest the climate
activists will climb on board because
it's for the good of the earth that is
their ladder to be on the platform. If
morality and Christian norms is the
ladder of the other one then that's
fine. Then the one has the mark in the
forehead and the other one has the mark
on the hand.
>> We've said this will be the glue and I
still believe it will be the glue to get
them all together.
>> Will be the glue.
>> All right, let's see how how acceptable
Al-Misan is, which is the Islamic
version of the reasons why you need a
climate activity.
>> Yeah. The Islamic Ladus.
>> Yes. So it's a covenant for the earth.
Martin, that's Gia worship, but let's
leave it at that. So, Al-Mizan is a
covenant for the earth presents an
Islamic outlook of the environment in a
bid to strengthen local, regional, and
international actions that combat
climate change and other threats to the
planet. It is a global endeavor,
global. So, it is a common platform to
climb onto the ladder of moral
legislation.
and Sunday is enscconced in it. You
cannot get rid of it. Al-Misan restates
the principles governing the protection
of nature and a form that meets current
challenges.
It is based on surah Raman the merciful
in which Allah almighty describes the
creation in its perfect balance. So we
have two deities
that uh according to two religious
systems require us to start implementing
moral legislation
>> for climate
>> and remember ladi also had very ga talk
in it brother son and sister moon or
whatever I can't even remember the right
words
>> now yeah Martin you have this issue of
Islam implementing Sharia law
And we saw that there was a human cry
that the Christian component of Europe
which believes that the basis was
Christian doesn't want to be under that
system. Right? And it was so fascinating
as we said before that Richard Dawkins
who's an atheist
>> says he is a cultural Christian. He
wants those laws. So modern when they
want to implement these Sharia laws
and the liberal governments are in
allowing it can they expect a backlash?
Oh definitely. Let's have a look.
Sharia law is now valid in Austria. A
court has ruled in a decision widely
condemned by locals. In a landmark legal
decision, the court ruled that a
contract made between two businessmen
using Sharia law is valid in the
country. One of the parties had taken
the case to the court pointing out
Sharia's arbitrary nature,
>> often being subject to wildly differing
interpretations by scholars and its
fundamental violation of Austrian law
and its principles. But the court slat
the argument down, explicitly stating
the Sharia agreement didn't contradict
Austrian values. The decision prompted
fury from the Conservative government.
Claudia Placon, Minister for Europe,
Integration, and Family said, "Sharia
has nothing to do with Austria and the
principles of our constitution." This is
the latest twist in Austria's checkered
relationship with political Islam. The
country was the first in Europe to
recognize the religion with its 1912
Islam law. But changes to the law
banning foreign funding for mosques led
to a backlash from Muslims who said the
state was spreading distrust of them. In
2017, the country banned the burka.
Britain is seeing its own growing
concern over the role of Sharia courts
in its society. Muhammad is the most
popular baby name in Britain for the
second year in a row. I'd like to
congratulate Muhammad on doing the
double. It's back-to- back victory for
Muhammad. There's been a 23% rise in the
number of little baby Muhammads in the
last year. The name K, by the way, has
died out.
>> Okay. Ammon, why why are we showing
these things?
>> We're showing that the world will be
splitting into moral conclaves
>> either controlled by Islam or by
Christianity.
At the moment, there is still this
conflict between the liberal thought and
the conservative thought. But the
backlash is becoming so great that there
is the shift to the conservative side.
>> Yes. And the pendulum is so where
previously the pendulum was completely
to the opposite side during the Biden
administration.
We said that it was actually more moving
in Europe at that stage and then it
moved in US
>> but not in the United Kingdom.
>> Not so much hanging in there. Let's see
what's going to happen.
>> But now it's starting to happen. It's
very interesting that uh Hollywood
brought out some movies and they have
some some little interesting little
anecdotes in there that we might just
look at.
>> Yeah, this is just linking on to what uh
that exitanic
>> what that say about the plan.
>> Listen to this. I've seen the earth laid
to waste. I've seen the horror to come.
Is it a sin to wish you were never born?
The thousand years have ended.
27.
A thousand years are ended.
When a thousand years are ended, Satan
shall be loosed out of his prison.
7.
>> I'm not the bad guy.
What about the end of days?
>> Think of it as a new beginning, a change
of management, and you'll be right there
with me on the ground floor. It will be
so cool.
>> Tell me what you want. Tell me what you
really want, and I'll give it to you.
>> I'm here on the ground with my nose in
it since the whole thing began. Who in
their right mind, Kevin, could possibly
deny the 20th century was entirely mine?
It's my time now.
>> Oh, that's pretty perfect.
Now, Martin will probably be accused of
date setting again.
>> We didn't say anything.
>> We're not date setting. We're just
looking at what these people have to
say. Uh I find it just interesting that
there seems to be this thing of a new
agenda coming.
>> Yeah.
and
>> from the satanic side, from all over,
>> from every side, from Hollywood. And by
the way, let's make it quite clear
again. Hollywood is Jesuit theater. And
the Jesuits are the enemies of Christ,
even though they call themselves the
Society of Jesus.
>> That's just
>> they hate the word.
>> Yeah,
>> it is their greatest enemies, this
poisonous asp.
And uh their main objective is to
destroy Protestant Christianity and
bring the world back to allegiance to
the papacy. And his mark of authority as
he claims is Sunday.
>> Sunday.
>> That's it. So Martin, what is the last
act in the drama?
Never did this message apply with
greater force than it applies today.
More and more the world is setting at
not the claims of God. Men have become
bold in transgression. The wickedness of
the inhabitants of the world has almost
filled up the measure of their iniquity.
This earth has almost reached the place
where God will permit the destroyer to
work his will upon it. Isn't that what
he just said? Well, it's my time now.
the substitution of the laws of men for
the laws of God. Even if they are packed
as moral Christian laws.
>> Yeah.
>> But they're not. They're moral papal
laws.
>> Yes.
>> So, let's read it again. The
substitution of the laws of men for the
law of God. The exaltation by merely
human authority of Sunday in place of
the Bible Sabbath is the last act in the
drama. When this substitution becomes
universal, God will reveal himself. He
will arise in his majesty to shake
terribly the earth. He will come out of
his place to punish the inhabitants of
the world for their iniquity. And the
earth shall disclose her blood and shall
no more cover a slain. Martin, we're on
the threshold of this.
>> If people don't see it in the
discussions that we've had, I doubt
whether we can ever open their m minds
or maybe the sleeping pills are so
effective that they don't even wake up.
The days in which we live are solemn and
important. The spirit of God is
gradually but surely being withdrawn
from the earth. Plagues and judgments
are already falling upon the despisers
of the grace of God. The calamities by
land and sea, the unsettled state of
society, the alarms of war are
potentious. Don't we have all of that?
We have to again go into Ukraine and
Iran and Iraq and whatever. No.
They forecast approaching events of the
greatest magnitude. The agencies of evil
are combining their forces and
consolidating.
They are strengthening for the Lord
great crisis. Great changes are soon to
take place in our world and the final
movements will be rapid ones. And he
said 250 years.
Do you believe that?
>> I think no. I do not believe that
because I think we are already in the in
the move final movements that are
starting to be rapid.
>> Exactly. So in my opinion whether it's
250 it might as well be 250 days.
>> Could happen. I'm not saying it is in
case somebody wants to say something
again.
>> Don't put words in our mouth. But
>> I won't be um surprised. Well, maybe it
will still be an overwhelming surprise.
That why we said you um are we ready?
>> Are we ready? Yeah. The epidemic of
crime. We are living in the midst of an
epidemic of crime at which thoughtful
God-fearing men everywhere stand a
ghast. The corruption that prevails is
beyond the power of the human pen to
describe. Every day brings fresh
revelations of political strife,
bribery, and fraud. Every day brings its
hearts sickening record of violence and
lawlessness, of indifference to human
suffering, of brutal fish destruction of
human life. Every day testifies to the
increase of insanity, murder, suicide.
Who can doubt that satanic agents are at
work amongst men with increasing
activity to distract and corrupt the
minds and defile and destroy the body.
No wonder they say if we don't correct
it now it's too late.
>> Yeah.
>> And you have the spirit of anarchy.
>> We've seen that now in few videos also.
>> All right. Exactly. Is permeating all
nations. And the outbreaks that from
time to time excite the horror of the
world are but indications of the pentup
fires of passion and lawlessness
that having once escaped control will
fill the earth with woe and desolation.
The condition of things in the world
shows that troub times are right upon
us. The daily papers are full of
indications of a terrible conflict in
the near future. Bold robberies are
frequent occurrence. Strikes are common.
Thefts and murders are committed on
every hand. Men possessed of demons are
taking the lives of men, women, and
little children. Men have become
infatuated with vice, and every species
of evil prevails. But is this a reality
or is this conjecture?
One case that must have rocked the world
of late must be the Corberger
situation. I mean, here is a PhD student
in criminology.
>> Yeah.
>> Studying these things. He's awkward and
he has uh all kinds of issues with
girls. And he goes and coldbloodedly
goes into a house and stabs to death
young people, young girls, and tries to
get away with it. Coldblooded murder for
the sake of the kick.
>> Yeah.
>> Isn't that
>> Well, that's the only explanation
because the motive is still not known.
>> No. No. Because uh girls seem to have
avoided him because of his awkwardness.
he was going to vent his anger upon them
and kill them. So Brian Corberger has
been sentenced to four consecutive life
terms because he finally admitted it and
he made a plea deal.
>> Yeah.
>> So that he wouldn't get the death
sentence. And now he's complaining that
the inmates are harassing him and he
wants special things. You know what's
amazing, Martin?
>> Mhm.
>> The man's a vegan.
>> Yeah.
>> Just throw that into the pile. Yeah. How
did that work?
>> How does that work? Right. This is just
fascinating to me how you can create
animosities against certain issues. We
don't have to read it all.
>> Now, we were re recently in Europe,
right? And we were walking there on this
boulevard in Lousern
and we saw these things there on the
sidewalk, these these big plastic
containers
and these ramps over here.
And uh we asked, "What are these?
>> What are they all about?" No matter
where you go on those streets, there
they are. And the people are walking
over here and you have your little
stalls and you can get a little snacks
there. And whenever there's some
cultural event here around this
beautiful sea, the people are walking
there. What are these things?
>> Concrete blocks.
>> They're concrete barriers.
>> And these are uh things to keep vehicles
out.
Why? Because people that are insane and
have become demonpossessed are taking
their cars and driving through crowds
and killing them.
>> So now this is a barrier to prevent cars
from driving in there.
>> But if there is an event then you need
an ambulance to get in there. So they
have these ramps over here so that they
can lower them that an ambulance can
come in.
>> So Martin is the world insane?
>> No. This is just prophecy being
fulfilled. So they are insane
unfortunately. So yeah,
>> do you think this is going to carry on
for another 250 years?
>> There's not nothing going to be left no
matter where you go. There they are. All
of these concrete blocks so that people
can't drive in and just kill people
indiscriminately. It hasn't happened
here yet.
>> Yeah.
>> But Europe
>> precautionary
>> is taking precautions.
What about grooming gangs in the UK
thrived in a culture of ignorance? So
cultural blindness, ignorance, prejudice
led to repeated failures over decades to
properly investigate cases in which
children were abused by grooming gangs.
The world is so deported and so sick
>> that no wonder Wilson says that if we
don't act now, our window of opportunity
is gone. There is an administration in
place. We have a direct line to the
administration. The administration has
issues in place or or putting it in
>> structures in place in order to
implemented.
They're bringing out the national guard
to bring order. Now, this is purely
civil order.
>> Yeah.
>> What about the underlying cause which is
moral?
>> It's getting there very soon. In the
latest visit, the South Korean president
visited Trump and in the after the with
the press conference that president was
luring uh Trump the whole time about he
must come and make peace between South
and North Korea and the that whole
meeting went
>> and is now talking about meeting Kim
Jong-un.
>> He's definitely he said it's going to
happen. He's boasting about how many
wars he's stopped. 35 years the Indian
won the 30 years in Congo.
>> Are they talking peace? Peace Martin.
>> It's the whole time. And why? Because
he's edging on bringing in the morality
side of Christianity.
>> All right. So Martin, when they say
peace, peace, what comes then?
>> Sudden destruction.
>> Isn't that an overwhelming dis surprise?
>> For sure. Okay. So, a British man
convicted of criminal charges for
praying silently near abortion clinics.
Now, this has been happening now that
Satan has said it would happen in by
2025 and it's certainly happening by
2025. It actually started happening
earlier than that already.
So, the court's reasoning betrayed the
absurdly sensorious nature of the local
law. So these are real issues that are
taking place and I believe they are
there to bring about a backlash.
>> I believe that too.
>> And to swing that pendulum to moral laws
and then Martin the mark of the beast
will be implemented and it could happen
within a very short window of
opportunity.
Even if there's some collateral damage,
it will be the lesser of two evils.
So Martin, get ready. Get ready. Get
ready. This is the reason why we are
talking about these issues.
Then my eyes were taken from the glory
and I was pointed to the remnant on the
earth. The angel said to them, "Will you
shun the seven last plagues? Will you go
to glory and enjoy all that God has
prepared for those who love him and are
willing to suffer for his sake? If so,
you must die that you may live. That's
dying to self. That's that reformation.
Get ready. Get ready. Get ready. You
must have a greater preparation than you
now have. For the day of the Lord cometh
cruel, both with wroth and fier.
It is that time that God calls his
unusual work.
>> God is not in into uh retributive
judgment. He wants everyone to be saved.
But the time of probation is coming to
an close.
You must have a greater preparation.
Why? Then you now have for the day of
the Lord cometh cruel both with wroth
and fierce anger to lay the land
desolate to destroy the sinners thereof
out of it. There's no millennium of
peace and safety here. And it's not
going to take 250 years to finally
implement it over the entire world.
>> No.
>> Sacrifice all to God. Lay all upon the
altar. Self, property, all. A living
sacrifice. It will take all to enter
glory. Lay up for yourselves treasures
in heaven where no thief can approach or
rust corrupt. You must be partakers of
Christ's sufferings here if you would be
partaketh with him of his glory
hereafter. And there will be no rapture,
Martin.
>> Because the Israelites were here when
the plagues fell.
God's people will be here when the
plagues fall because type has to meet
anti-ype. The destruction came and they
were taken out of their captivity. The
destructural will come now and then
God's people will be taken out of their
captivity.
That portion of the plagues falling and
we being protected by God to go through
it is actually another example of his
protection over us and example to the
rest of the world.
>> But when those plagues fall, probation
will be closed for the world. The
decision time is when?
>> Now. Now. So, Martin, let's have a look
at Europe and see if it'll take 250
years to get that mindset into place.
The BBC reports on the 25th of August,
that the national flags have started
lining our streets. They may say
something more. M
>> people are hoisting national flags.
Driving through the southwest of
Birmingham, it's hard not to notice
something about the lamp posts. For more
than a mile, almost everyone has a St.
George or Union Jack flag attached to
it. Thousands of them. In fact, Martin,
they are saying, "We want our old system
back. We're tired of all this
immigration. we're tired of all this
strange activity. We want to have our
conservative values. And they actually
said that if there were an election now,
it would favor the conservative side.
>> Yeah, for sure. And and another thing is
the mainstream media is not actually
giving attention to this. No,
>> there's so much more happening that you
don't even see.
>> Correct. And even in France,
the media,
worldwide media is hammering all the
liberal values. Whether they're talking
about issues of Macron and his wife
>> or saying, you know, look, this world is
a deborged world and look at the people
that are leading this world and let's
move to a more val moral side. But it
can happen overnight.
>> And remember, we people must not forget
that bringing that conservative
morality.
The Catholic system has room for it.
That's actually Vatican prevatican 2.
>> Correct. And unlike the United States,
>> the laws in Europe are already in place
and don't have to be reactivated or
anything of that nature. So what they
say here that the latest phenomenon
started in mid July in Woolly Castle and
spread to neighboring areas. In the last
week it has ripped not just across the
Midlands but other parts of England
including Worcester, Bradford, Greater
Manchester, Newcastle, Norwich. It's a
sudden movement. The last events will be
what?
>> Rapid
>> rapid ones. And Trump signs executive
order establishing specialized National
Guard units to address crime in the
city. Are they proactive? Are they
putting in place
government authority in places now under
this guise of let's not for crime to
prevent crime.
>> Do we have anarchy? Do we have
opposition from the left? Are they
screaming blue murder? Is it being
implemented
>> finished
>> slowly and gently? Right.
>> No, unfortunately not. Just rap it.
>> This is happening right there. He says
it and it goes.
>> Okay. So, what did the Secretary of
Defense Pete Hexstead have to do with
it? Well, with establishing specialized
units in the National Guard that will be
specifically trained and equipped to
deal with public order issues. The
clearest sign yet, he intends to expand
the US military's role in domestic law
enforcement activities across the
country. Martin, can this set the stage
for even enforcing moral law?
>> Listen, if the Sunday, if blue laws are
implemented, who will then enforce it?
>> And did we just show that Pete Hexstead
has a direct line to Wilson and to
Donald Trump?
>> No, for sure. No. This is re it's I
think it's time to wake up.
>> Modern sleeping is so comfortable.
>> Now we spoke to people that are mainly
evangelicals, right?
>> Yeah. And we told them straight out and
the guys from Heritage and Hope told
them straight out that the position that
we hold is the same as that the
Protestant reformers held that Rome is
the antichrist.
But here we read that the Catholics are
becoming the new mainline. We even
mentioned it. We even mentioned it. Yes.
>> To to Douglas Wilson. We said the
administration and everybody is run by
this. And he said and his words was not
everybody will probably agree with him
on how it has to be implemented.
Correct. All right. So Martin
this is what is happening. The Catholic
Church is increasingly functioning as
the new mainline church in American
politics where left, right and center
gather to receive Jesus.
Leo's pontificate is a capstone
What is a capstone?
>> Well, wasn't there a rejection of a
capstone in the time of Jesus?
>> Yes.
>> It seems there's an acceptance of
another capstone over here, a pope.
>> Yes.
>> An antichrist.
>> One in the place of Jesus Christ.
>> To the long maturation of Catholic faith
in America. The most important Catholic
is now an American. So naturally being
an American is becoming Catholic.
Isn't that interesting Martin?
>> So Martin when they say I knew it captus
no ordo seclorum out of many one they're
going to unify. Are they doing it?
>> That capstone is coming I think is on
top of the pyramid now. It's coming
right down and it's the eye of Lucifer.
>> Hype around America's first pop
>> now reaching new heights with viral
videos of shirts, hats, and pizzas
getting handd delivered to the Chicago
born pontiff,
including two dry ice packed pies carted
to Rome today from Aurelios. The Chicago
staple going allin on Papal Madness,
dubbing one pizza the Poperoni after the
then Cardinal ate here last summer.
You've hosted then future presidents.
You've hosted boxing legends. They don't
have their own table though.
>> No, no. The Pope is our number one fan
and number one customer.
>> This faithful in from New Mexico.
>> You can travel to the bean uh downtown
or see Wrigley Field, but this is way
more special. The fanfare consuming
Chicago. Pope Leo lookalikes now
regulars at White Sox games. The real
lifelong fan delivering this message.
>> My dear friends, it's a pleasure for me
to greet all of you.
>> Holy devotion now hitting the streets.
>> You've launched a Pope themed bus tour.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> That's like the most American thing
ever.
>> I know.
>> Chicago Pope Tours held its inaugural
trip Sunday, taking patrons to Pope Leo
Seminary. even his childhood home.
>> I think the sense of community that
happened was really important.
>> A growing connection to America's first
pontiff that sparked a pope culture
frenzy. Maggie Vespa, NBC News, Chicago.
>> All right, it's time to start wrapping
this up.
Is the table set?
Do you need others glasses to see that
it is? Is the mortal wound healed?
>> It's I think with this last pop I think
we
>> it's coming to fruition. Is is
everything coming to a culmination
point?
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Everything that scripture said that the
second beast which is the United States
of America will give its power or its
authority and its clout and put it at
the disposal of the first beast by
implementing his authority.
Aren't they going to want to implement
Sunday? Didn't he say so?
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Didn't they say so?
>> Definitely.
>> So, that's the moral power of the
papacy, not the moral power of the Bible
because that's Sabbath.
>> Yeah.
>> So, Martin,
can we ask the question, are we
alarmists and sensationalists because we
are talking about these issues now?
>> I hope that people can start seeing that
this is not the case.
>> This is just reality. Did he Wilson say
that we must act now before it's too
late and the lesser evil must be
tolerated for the sake of stopping the
greater evil? Yeah. They feel that they
only have a short window of opportunity.
Did we discuss that?
And that must obviously be the Trump
administration
and that gives us until 2028
because what if they lose then then
we're back to square one, right?
So they want to stem the tide of evil
and if the other side wins maybe it'll
be too late. Martin 2028 is there. I'm
not saying that Christ will come in 2028
but the occult agenda from 2025 to 2027
>> is in place.
>> Y
>> the the uh religious will to implement
these things. Project 2025 was implement
and in six months
>> the political will in other words
>> I mean how much has been implemented in
the last six months by this
administration.
>> Amazing. Amazing. So modern does this
mean it could happen before then?
History and prophecy will prove them
wrong.
By that I mean that they don't want to
have persecution. But history and
prophecy will prove that they will
implement it because wherever it has
been introduced, it has led to
persecution.
>> That's it.
>> And I believe we are in the final
events. So there are some lessons from
Elijah's experience. From Elijah's
experience during these days of
discouragement and apparent defeat,
there are many lessons to be drawn.
lessons invaluable to the servants of
God in this age, marked as it is by
general departure from right. The
apostasy prevailing today is similar to
that in the prophet's day that
overspread Israel. In the exaltation of
human above the divine, the praise of
the popular leaders, the worship of
Mammon, the placing of the teachings of
science above the truth of revelation.
Multitudes today are following after
Baal. The enemy of all truth is working
with deceptive power to cause men and
women to place human institutions where
God should be. Did we demonstrate that?
>> For sure.
>> And to forget that which was ordained
for the happiness and salvation of
mankind. Yet
this apostasy widespread as it is has
come to be is not universal. Martin this
is very hopeful.
Not all in the world are lawless and sin
sinful. Not all have taken sides with
the enemy. God has many thousands who
have not bowed the need to bail. Many
who long to understand more fully in
regard to Christ and the law. Many who
are hoping against hope that Jesus will
come soon to end the reign of sin and
death. And there are many who have been
worshiping Baal ignorantly, but with
whom the spirit of God is still
striving. But here's the bottom line.
when these events start taking place,
I hope that the leaders and the shakers
that some of them at least
>> and I particularly pray for Wilson and
Lenox
>> because they've been confronted with the
issue now that they will see it and use
their influence to sway many to follow
the Bible directive
>> so that many can embrace the truth as it
is in Jesus. That is the reason and why
we should have the privilege
of being able to speak with these people
is is beyond me. It is mindblowing to me
and we must thank God for the
opportunity that he gave us. The
opportunity was not at this stage to
change their position but the
opportunity is there to wake up God's
people.
>> Yeah. in terms of the times in which we
are living. I think it is time we closed
in prayer.
>> Yeah.
>> Heavenly Father,
it is with a feeling of foroding
that I believe that an overwhelming
surprise is around the corner
and the church according to scripture
has sleeping virgins.
And Lord, if they do not wake up before
these events,
but only wake up when the shout goes
out, the bridegroom,
it's come,
it'll be too late.
So I pray that they will wake up up,
wake up now.
And not only they, but that they will be
empowered
to preach the message of the third angel
with power so that the whole world can
be enlightened with its glory.
This is my prayer in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen.
[Music]